[Musique]
il était ouvrier à l'usiné rhodia c'est
ta de besançon ou chez peugeot à sochaux
et ils ont fait du cinéma
une expérience unique en france une
utopie qui a changé la vie de ceux qui
l'ont portée
je suis très heureux d'avoir traversé
cette période parce que c'est une
période de très mouvementée et une
période où hommes et femmes ou des
hommes et des femmes vont se transformer
c'est à dire on va on va devenir
d'autres personnes et c'est ça le plus
important c'est l'émancipation
c'est l'occasion pour nous d'être
confronté à l'art sous toutes ses formes
peinture sculpture théâtre littérature
etc etc
et cette confrontation justement va nous
transformer leur mai 68 à eux avaient en
réalité démarré dès février 67 avec la
grande grève de l'usiné rhodia et
l'engagement du centre culturel
populaire de palente les hors champ qui
appelle alors le cinéaste chris marker à
venir filmer le conflit si vous n'êtes
pas cuba oies ou voyeur venir c'est fait
le déplacement de crise marqué par chris
marker a aussi parlé de son expérience
bisontine à d'autres grands cinéastes
qui sont venus aussi apporter leur
soutien à l'image de jean luc godard qui
offre une caméra super 8 ou de cinéastes
expérimentés qui viennent former les
ouvriers aux rudiments du cinéma leur
premier film s'appellera classe de lutte
la première fois que j'ai eu l'année 16
mm c'est comme si j'avais dans mes bras
une femme et donc c'est c'est un moment
de grâce c'est un moment douloureux
parce qu'on sait pas on sait pas comment
ça va se passer avec cet objet ou sais
pas comment ça va se passer
besançon ville franc comtoise ville
comme tout le monde on s'y ennuie le
dimanche pendant la semaine on y
travaille là ce qui est important c'est
que pour la première fois en france des
ouvriers prennent la caméra et la
prennent
totalement c'est à dire ils vont
concevoir eux-mêmes leurs propres films
nous ne pouvons pas accepter la division
jusqu'à maintenant nous avons décidé de
la grèce
enfin à cinéma militant qui inspire
encore aujourd'hui de jeunes cinéastes
et qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses
thèses un parent et nous devons
continuer notre lutte
c'était aussi un point de départ pour de
jeunes cinéastes en formation des gens
qui ont découvert aussi cette forme de
cinéma
cette forme de d'activités militantes
d'action et qu'on trouvait là des
terrains nouveau l'expérience des
groupes medvedkine se prolongera
jusqu'en 1974 elle aura permis aux
ouvriers d'avoir accès à la culture et
au ccp ou d'organiser des rencontres
cinématographiques ccpp ou est toujours
là plus peut-être modestement mais quand
même bien présent avec toujours dans cet
esprit de découverte de lutte de
résistance 68 n'est pas morts on veut
l'enterrer mai 68 n'est pas mort au
contraire il est mise en valeur et au
jour et aujourd'hui puisque plus lierre
plus qu'hier
tous les films de cette époque ont été
compilées pour être à nouveau diffusés
hommage au cinéaste ouvriers de franche
comté
[Musique]
oh